Fun fact, I bet you didn't know. You can
turn those poi weaves into a flower. We
call this move a fountain. And it's not
as complicated as it looks. I remember
seeing a video of this on Home of Poi
back in the day and finding it utterly
mysterious. The thing is though, you
probably already have the pieces for
this. If you can do your forwards and
reverse weaves, you're already there.
So, let me show you how to put those
pieces together into a fountain.
Drex here from Drexfactor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in today's video, I'm going
to show you how to get down what we call
a sixbeat poi fountain. But before we
dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroera Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-b businessiness friend
of the channel, Becca Beckon. Thank you
so much for supporting my channel, my
work, and my mission. All right. So,
prerequisites for this one are that you
have to have down your forwards three
beat weaves and your reverse threebeat
weaves because we're going to go back
and forth between them a lot in the
course of this video. I'm going to go
ahead and include links to tutorials for
both of these up in the cards as well as
down in the description. Simply said, if
you've got both of them, then you
basically have all the pieces you need
already. So, the first thing that you're
going to need to have a good grasp on is
something called the waist wrap. A waist
wrap is just a turn back and forth
between a forwards and reverse threebeat
weave. I usually think of setting myself
up in such a way that I'm going to
perform my forwards weave over on my
stage right and my reverse weave over on
my stage left. So I would turn my upper
body over to face that wall to my right
when performing my forwards three beat
weave. And I would pivot my upper body
over to face to the left if I'm
performing that reverse three beat
weave. It's really important that you
perform these weaves against opposite
walls. Otherwise, this doesn't quite
line up right. So, how do we get back
and forth between them? I'm so glad you
asked. When we head over to our right
hand side and perform that forwards
three beat weave, I want you to pay
careful attention to this point where
your left hand is going around over your
right hand. It happens right here. This
is actually a moment when you can
separate your hands for a second and
exit the forward three beat weave
entirely. Now, the cool thing about this
is it's also a moment when you can enter
into the reverse threebeat weave.
Namely, I can take my right hand and
swing it under my left. And that begins
a reverse three beat weave over here.
This is the move that carries both of my
hands back around all the way to my left
as I perform that reverse weave. Now,
I'm looking for the moment in the
reverse weave when my right hand is
coming around under my left hand. It
happens right here. And once again, this
is a moment when I can pause and exit
the weave for a second. And you might
have guessed it, it's also an
opportunity for me to go back into that
forwards three beat weave by having my
left hand reach up and over and cross
over my right hand po. So from this
central position right here, I have the
option of taking my left hand over my
right to get into the forwards three
beat weave over on stage right or I can
bring my right hand under my left to
carry them both over to stage left in a
reverse threebeat weave. I open, bring
left hand over. I open, bring right hand
under. I open, bring left hand over. I
open, bring right hand under. If I take
out the openings, I wind up performing a
full waist strap where I'm going back
and forth between the forwards and
reverse three beat weaves just like
this. Now, once you're able to perform
those waist straps, it's really
important that you be able to go just
straight back and forth from the forward
to the reverse side. And you'll notice
whenever you do that, there's that
moment where the poi and hands are
passing around on your downstage side in
a straight line from side to side, going
to your right and going to your left and
going back to your right like so. You
want to make sure you're only getting in
one rep of each weave. And we're going
to tweak what happens as you're carrying
these poi back and forth across your
body to make that fountain happen. So,
as you're taking your hands back and
forth, I want you to notice that they
seem to move in more or less a
horizontal but straight line. Now, the
thing is we can actually open up that
line. Let me show you what I mean. From
the forwards weave, when we take our
hands across our body to the reverse
side, we can actually take them down and
around past our hips. Again, I want you
to check this out. Taking them down and
around over to your reverse side. Try
doing that a few times, maybe five of
them. Going
once and then
[Applause]
twice and then three
times, four
times and five times down and around
past your hips. Okay. So, if taking them
down around past your hips when going
from forwards to reverse is feeling
comfortable, now we can practice taking
them up and over from the reverse side
to the forward side like so. Basically,
we're reaching both of our hands up and
around. You might find when you start
off doing this that you separate your
hands a little bit as you go up and
over. That's perfectly fine when you're
starting out, but as you practice this,
I want you to work on keeping the gap
between your hands as narrow as
possible. Once again, we want to go over
once and
twice and three
times and four
times and five times going up and over.
Heck, you may have done the down and
around or up and over accidentally at
some point, not even realized it. But
now it's time to put the two of them
together. All right. So, from that
forward side, I want you to go ahead and
take it down and around heading to your
reverse. And then from your reverse
side, I want you to take it up and over
going to the forwards. So, from forwards
on stage right, down and around to
reverse on stage left, and then up and
over, back to stage right. Maybe count
one,
two, three weaves before you go down and
around. and
one,
two, three weaves before going up and
over. Then we do
one, two, down and around.
One, two, up and over. And then we just
think down and around, up and over, down
and around, up and over. And
congratulations, you now have a poi
fountain under your belt. Well done. And
just to give you a little bit of theory
as you're playing around with this,
because it's based in performing a pair
of three beat weaves, we would refer to
this as a sixbeat fountain. There are
actually other fountains out there that
have different number of beats to them,
but this is the basic fountain that's
been around well longer than I've been
spinning poi. So, it's kind of the
default option. And just to put this out
there, if you'd like an extra special
challenge as you're working with your
fountains, there is actually a way that
you can turn them inside out and create
anti-pin fountains without too much
change from what you already know how to
do. Here's how. Let's start off with our
reverse weaves over on our stage left
side. As we're performing these reverse
weaves, we're used to taking them up and
over in order to get to our forwards
weaves, but we don't have to. Instead,
at that moment when we would go up and
over, we can instead take them down and
around. We're still performing the exact
same weave motion. Just happens to be
that it goes down instead of up. And it
changes the quality of movement in the
fountain as well, where now we have the
poi moving in sharper pedals rather than
broader and rounder ones. We can do the
same thing over here on the forward
side, taking our hands up and over as we
go to the reverse. And then going ahead
and taking them down and around from
reverse to forwards. So on the anti-
spin side, we go from forwards up and
over to reverse. And then from reverse,
we go down and around to forwards, up
and over to reverse, down and around to
forwards. And hey, check that out.
You're doing what might just be your
first anti-pin PO move. And it has to be
said, you can switch between the inspin
and anti-pin versions of the fountain
whenever you want. I personally think it
looks pretty cool to do that. Awesome.
So, if you would like some more PO
exercises in your life, then I have a
tip for you and it is called the flow
circle. The flow circle is a weekly
exclusive lesson that's available only
to my Patreon supporters. In each weekly
drill or exercise, you'll be getting
down a new PO technique, trick, or
theory that will help you progress with
your PO spinning and gain mastery over
the prop. You can check that out over at
patreon.com/directfactorploy. If this
video was helpful, I would really
appreciate it if you would leave a like,
a comment, share, or subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a huge
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed right here on screen with me.
Thank you all so much. I could not do
this without you. And if you out there
watching enjoy the content that I create
and you want to see me make more of it,
the best way to do that is to sign up to
support this work over on Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo. There you can
get access to a whole host of amazing
rewards. But even better than that,
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring po spinning and flow arts to
the whole wide world. Go check that out,
please and thank you. And if you'd like
to learn more about PO fountains,
including how to perform fourbeat
fountains or whether there are
additional B fountains, etc., uh, I will
go ahead and include a link to a video I
did recently outlining the theory of
that. Go check it out. It's pretty
awesome. And in the meantime, please
make sure to get out and flow
yourselves. And I will see you with a
new video real soon. Take care now.
Peace.